did i hear that you took up a special
hobby during the whole uh shutdown the
whole kovid shutdown what is it who was
it i was told you were doing pole
dancing oh yes well i was doing it
before the pandemi um and then during
the pandemic i spent a lot of time doing
it because i was like what the [ __ ] else
am i gonna do but yeah i love politics
it's hard i have to say i
years ago uh
i took a course
because there was a i was taught a
course on the late night show and
someone came on and was showing me how
to pole dance and i was stunned at how
how hard it is to support your body on
that pole it's so hard and then you wake
up the next day and you're like hmm
muscles i didn't know i have yeah but so
many single dollar bills so many i don't
know how the girls dance over the dollar
bills and don't slip and fall oh because
i slip and fall over nothing i think
there's a lot there's just a lot you
need to learn if you're gonna be a
stripper
i would love to be a stripper would you
really oh yes if i had just taken a
couple different paths probably i'd be a
stripper yeah i think it's fun it might
be fun to do once but to do it over and
over and over again that same creepy guy
always gets the same chair at the bar
keeps asking for pour some sugar on me
and keeps
holding a very small bill out that
you're supposed to come over
and squeeze it between your titties you
know
and then you look at it it's like a two
dollar bill
who's on the two dollar bill i think
it's gerald ford but anyway it's very
it's not a good bill who is on the true
dollar bill thomas jefferson
is it i got it right
yeah that's right it is thomas jefferson
yeah i have a bunch of two dollar bills
do you really any time i get when i keep
it i keep them too yeah every now and
then
we have all seven
all seven two dollar bills that are left
in circulation
i have one as well this is like four or
five of them i feel like i like them
this is a date this is us making a
connection on a date
it's about two dollar bills i have some
as well
who's on it do you think well it's
jefferson it is jefferson among us we
have later at a wedding later at a
wedding chapel in vegas
i mean that is kind of like a first date
first dates suck
i really hate them
it's just small talk for like an hour
and a half yeah i haven't been on a
first date since
i think it was 1971
so it's been a long really no i'm
kidding
i'm not that i was like that's so loud
i'm not that old
how old are you
[Laughter]
i was uh no i but it's been so long i
mean it was my yeah my wife is my last
first date it better be my last first
date that would be yeah i've been
together uh 22 years oh that's so nice
yeah it is good
i should probably put in a better
response then yeah
he went oh 22 that's so nice yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah we've been at 22 years she it's
been really great she
i love it that's very nice that's what i
want 22 years that seems nice i'm not
sure you do want that
what conan i'm sorry i i'm just i'm like
a provocative therapist
this is my job
well in the past you said you want to
[ __ ] yes but i told you i'm horny for
love right but do you want do are you
looking for someone who you'll marry and
grow old with
well i don't know if i want to get like
married married
um but i do want like a partner and i do
not really want to grow old in general
because like the older i get the more
things hurt so i'd like to stop time
here but i would like to spend time with
someone for a long time that's nice
i i believe call me romantic if you put
them
thank you
i believe that if you put that out there
that it happens i really do i think when
you're ready for it and you put that out
there which you just did
uh that can happen for you well from
your lips to god's ears is that the
saying yeah but it's not god who's
involved in this who is it well i
believe it's from your mouth to god's
south
wow what does that mean
i don't know just what happened what
happened to you
how about this girly write the write
them down first
write them down first and pass them over
to david and if he thinks they're good
he'll give you the thumbs up meaning
dick
oh meaning
oh no
give me that god dick
oh okay i don't think i want god's dick
let me explain something
he has a new baby and he's sleep
deprived what kind
we got a girl oh that's nice she's a
sweetheart do you like her i love her to
tears wait she's brand new she's nine
months oh okay yeah and she'll give her
time you'll get annoyed oh
also he's not getting any sleep that was
the whole point of this
and so he just lately has been saying
stuff
um and all of us are scratching our
heads we don't know what's happening
with him